في اضنه التي كنا فيها حقيقه مباني حديثه
حديثه الانشاء ومن المفترض انها ضمن
معايير التي وضعتها الحكومه لمقاومه
الزلازل وتنهار كعلب الكبريت هذا الموضوع
اثار سخطا في الشارع لاسيما عند ذوي
الضحايا الذين فقدوا ضحاياهم كان هذا
السؤال محير كيف انهارت هذه الابنيه بهذه
السرعه وكان هناك البعض يقول ان قوه
الزلزال لا سيما ان المنطقه شهدت زلزالين
متتاليين
شده شده الاول
7.8 وثاني سبعه فاصله سته وهذا مع فسر هذا
الانهيار الكبير لكن مع ذلك كان هناك كان
كان يجب البحث في
حيثيات هذا الموضوع وتم القبض فعلا على
المقاولين هناك لا شك استياء في بعض في
الشارع نتيجه انهيار خصوصا نتحدث عن جديده
لم يمضي عليها الا بضع سنوات وبالتالي هذا
السؤال محير يعني كان من المفترض بحسب ما
يقوله البعض ان تقاوم اكثر من ذلك ربما
يكون هناك تصدعات لكن لا ان تنهار على
بالمطلق ولذلك هذا الموضوع
دفع او هذه التساؤلات دفعت السلطات
التركيه للتحرك وبدا عمليه القبض على
المقاولين ومن ثم بدا عمليات التحقيق في
هذا الموضوع